in genere io canto insomma queste luci
di ucina però non
per marca
al filo ce l'ho qui fatto 5.000 km
figura per questo a livorno ferraris non
buona
chissenefrega
[Musica]
ho preparato delle canzoni che non sono
buone per le due primati mangia perché
sono un po in tema perché quando vado a
suonare per la padania libera c'è un
altro repertorio farò le canzoni diciamo
abbastanza in tema su quello che ha
sempre fatto arrabbiare allo
sfruttamento dell'uomo principalmente
però vorrei anche di mostrarvi parlando
anche di come si può dire economia
specialmente del territorio delle
possibilità che si possano avere col
fatto che mi è successo che manlevato
due volte la corrente l'elettricità in
casa quindi ho capito che si può vivere
senza corrente elettrica
anche perché diciamo la compagna più il
tempo passa più è bruttina quindi meno
la vedo meglio sto è anche lei è
semplice anche
vi dimostrerò che senza corrente
elettrica io dico lo stesso
con una canzone di piero ciampi che che
un mio concittadino come modigliani come
modigliani che la mostra è stata fatta a
pisa e questo proprio non l'ho capito e
non l'ho ben digerito non per fare non
per fare per forza insomma
[Musica]
colpa del quelli della padania che ma
non può inculcate
fino all'ultimo minuto
t hotel
foto accanto a me fino all'ultimo minuto
non volevo dirti addio
ma tu non ascolti quelle voci senza
suolo che si cercano sul mare e ha
bisogno di qualcuno
fino all ultimo minuto
[Musica]
io ho tenuto accanto a me fino al minuto
non volevo dirti addio nato non ha scopi
quelle voci senza suono
che si cercano sul male e ha bisogno di
qua no siccome nei teatri non ci vado
mai a meno che non si paghi nulla
volevo proprio divertirmi un po a
sentire il suono di questo luogo in
genere non certo non sono qui per
lamentarmi a 52 anni non ho mai lavorato
in vita mia di che cazzo vediamo la meta
che cosa fare la vita bo sfrutto il
bambino che m
ma non è che commetto atti pedofili con
me stesso è così lo strutto però penso
al fatto che se un giorno mi va bene
sarò vecchio già ci sono
un po perché me ne accorgo perché dormo
meno poi quando c'è da prendere un treno
su mezzo ora prima poi mi danno noia i
motorini che vanno come dicevamo è mio
amico della i motorini quando scassano
troppo gli danno noia i fan bestemmiare
poi mangi le cioccolatini e di nascosto
questa insomma è quindi penso al fatto
che se ci va bene diventiamo vecchi
quindi spesso si manca di rispetto a chi
c'ha came libia i capelli bianchi no
questi giovinastri alle volte si
ammazzano l'altro poi trovano l'anziana
più debole insomma e io scrissi questa
canzone insomma per per far nascere
dentro noi questo questo fatto che se ti
va bene diventi vecchie quindi non
rompere i [ __ ] e poi
quindi una canzone di un'allegria
proprio estrema lo dico però siccome ci
avete tanta da mangia faccio poi ci si
va bene una luce di ucina fa vedere se
c'è qualche si abbona
[Musica]
vado
il vecchio e non solo
[Musica]
con lo sguardo al cielo che cerca
ragioni
per vivere ancora su una panchina
sia felice solo
[Musica]
quando non si sogna quando si sogna
poi viene la sera
e sorride il vecchio
sembra contento
la scusa è infranto
mentre il suo ira
le ultime foglie
sono già chiuse per l'ultima danza e
troverà
per vento d'autunno prima che riprenda
l'altra
e come in un sogno
il vecchio stanco vola nel vento
[Musica]
poi arriva duomo
dal camice bianco
[Musica]
e va verso il vecchio per forzarlo
dentro
ma payson gun
più di un ultima foglia il vecchio
volare
l'ultima danza
nessuno sa se sparito nel nulla
rossello abbia ripreso nato
è come un sogno
il vecchio stanco
[Musica]
su una panchina
sii felice solo quando si sogna
sì
[Musica]
cosa si sogna la casa in campagna è
l'auto più bella da cambiare ogni anno e
poi cellulare che fa le foto sott'acqua
e fame in foto a questa mia minchia come
viene sott'acqua e poi tutti a roma a
gridare pace vogliamo la pace la pace
pac man show ennio anche tu sei qui
faccio sentire dai pac
hai visto hai visto la bambina si è
laureata sei lì abbiamo contato una
bella 500 perché è bello questa macchina
italiana che ieri viene fuori è
bellissima jackass è rotto il rolex
cosa si sogna un mondo più meglio qui
non si sogna
allora fra tutti un po di pudore
vergogna
a cominciare da me con questa chitarra
[Musica]
non importa la cloud nel porto la fase
pre anche l'ora di andare a mangiare mi
sa se è vero che chi fa ginnastica prima
me ci parlava di cartello faccio un
altro brano come dono da software cosa
mi fa parte tutte belle le gli
interventi ho sentiti un po di gente col
con il quale andrea cena voletti aria
però poi mi piace proprio che il
presidente e musica si sa amano detto
che voleva di persona per questo se aver
rilasciato perché posso dire a parte me
che sono mi sento io mito per me stesso
però musica insomma per me è una specie
di mito
mi piace proprio perché siamo stati
abituati da una frase continua che
diceva un certo signore coi capelli
tinti e incipriato poi dice in albano le
ragazze giovani marzo momento a chi non
gli garba le ragazze giovani problema
dei problemi veri di lui insomma dei
guai sono sono altri però insomma
camuffato bene queste ragazze di giovani
che diceva sempre scendo in campo scendo
in campo la musica è uno che vive nel
campo caro signor presidente del nulla
lui l'uomo all'uomo proprio feed che da
lui lesempio come primo cittadino di
come bisogna comportarsi vivere che me
ne faccio di tutti questi soldi
c'è gente ha un amore suda molto di più
e guadagna meno
insomma finalmente un presidente sano
nella mia vita è esistito quindi non so
che altra canzone non ho idea perchè
devo pensare a quelle facce quando c'è
salvini
stasera aspetta stavo pensando scrissi
labbra scritto la canzone è coincisa ora
per la canzone un po che l'avevo scritta
nessun altro mia idea di mito non questo
si chiama il maestro cosmit praticamente
un signore che è esistito guardando la
storia dago di c'era la storia di cosmit
il maestro praticamente che nel ghetto
di varsavia
oltre a essere un grande pedagogo che
ancora oggi insomma il suo pensiero è
tuttora attuale e non ancora raggiunto
perché molto avanti insomma mise su un
orfanatrofio per bambini abbandonati nel
ghetto di varsavia tanto che li accudiva
segnava anche loro e poi quando decisero
insomma di deportare i bambini lui pur
potendo salvarsi scelse di accompagnarli
nel viaggio verso la deportazione pare
morì non arrivò nemmeno ad auschwitz
forse non sa rausch c'era un altro bel
sensor cibo e morì nel nel vagone quindi
la canzone tina a cosa serve serve a
ricordare che è esistito questo signore
così tanto per ingentilire che soffre
tanto per per commuovere laddove è il
caso che ci si possa commuovere a uno
dei più grandi poeti viventi che maestro
cosmit perché chi che dalla vita dei
bambini è un poeta assoluto poeta è
colui che fa lui che fa bla bla bla
per questo non lo sono
[Musica]
dagli occhi tuoi girotondi di bambini
che si prendono per mano sotto un grande
arcobaleno
[Musica]
perché tu hai il mistero dell'amore
gioia di contemplazione mentre altri
cuori corrono felici e gli occhi tuoi
c'è uno specchio dove vedo è se come io
vorrei e gli occhi tuoi
c'è l'immensità del cielo che si inchina
si fa pure della luce del divino
[Musica]
cantando vai
tra i cori dei bambini nella gloria del
trionfo della notte
e gli occhi fuori
c'è l'immensità del cielo che si inchina
e si fa chiaro della luce del divino
tenetevi germania
che presso arriverà
verso l'arco ball
prendetevi per mano
che presso noi sarà
nessun orco bordo
[Musica]
bello
ciò che
spero
speso
non so
sveva
ob
[Musica]
[Applauso]
la statua questo di rodari che io ho
musicato
[Applauso]
è di tutti
[Musica]
io
no
[Musica]
lei
per me
[Musica]
il prof
perché ciarlo solo perché tutta questa
gente numero
grazie